los yuyanos o vuelven a las urnas el día
de hoy martes para una segunda vuelta
que tendrá lugar apenas a cuatro semanas
después de que depositaron su voto en
las elecciones de mitad de mandato de
este año en Estados Unidos esta dotación
podría dar a los demócratas una mayoría
ligeramente más cómoda en el senado
analizamos entonces las claves de esta
elección con nuestro primer invitado del
día él es Rafael piñeros experto en
temas de Estados Unidos y también
profesor de relaciones internacionales
en la universidad externado de Colombia
Rafael Qué bueno tenerlo nuevamente en
el estudio buena mañana de martes Lo
mismo para ti muchas gracias por la
invitación Rafael hablemos de primero la
importancia de esta elección en Georgia
esta segunda vuelta y 12 afroamericanos
se enfrentan Cuál es la importancia
digamos también simbólica de esta
representación de los afroamericanos
bueno en primer lugar hay que mencionar
que en la primera vez que dos
afroamericanos representan a los
principales partidos políticos y tienen
la opción de llegar al senado en segundo
lugar la elección de ge importante
porque se ha convertido en un estado
relativamente competitivo donde los
demócratas No ganaban desde la década
del 60 y en las últimas elecciones lo
han hecho bastante bien De hecho uno de
los candidatos que es el senador
actualmente por el partido demócrata
Rafael Warner ganó en hace dos años en
una elección también atípica entonces
refleja que los demócratas han hecho
competitivo un estado que
tradicionalmente no lo era En tercer
lugar es importante la elección en
Georgia porque le permitiría a los
demócratas poner un senador más para
lograr 51 Y eso les da un cupo más en
los distintos comités donde lo quieran
poner al interior del senado y al mismo
tiempo disminuye la importancia
estratégica que tienen senadores de
centro
como Joe manching de Virginia occidental
o Selena Walmart de Arizona ese elemento
creo que le podría consolidar al menos
algunas votaciones al partido demócrata
al interior del senado hablemos Rafael
de candidato republicano apoyado por el
expresidente Donald Trump a la antigua
también estrella del fútbol americano en
Estados Unidos y también por otra parte
también
andemos un poco más en Rafael guanon el
titular demócrata y también pastor
Bautista bueno ha sido para para
herschelle Walker ha sido una
competencia que algunos dicen no estaba
preparado para ello sin duda alguna es
cercano al presidente Donald Trump y
tiene múltiples acusaciones tanto de
violencia doméstica como de incitación
al aborto a algunas de sus exparejas a
pesar de ser opositor Público de ese
tipo de medidas Entonces ha sido
supremamente criticado y cuando se
analizan las votaciones internas por
grupos étnicos uno se da cuenta de que
la población negra no lo está apoyando
como se supone que lo debería hacer los
cálculos más halagüeños de los
republicanos hablan de que las
elecciones presenciales hoy debería
votar aproximadamente el 60% de la gente
si quieren ganar por él y no lo veo tan
tan fácil ahora por el otro lado tenemos
un pastor de una Iglesia Bautista
trabajo comunitario de toda la vida a
veces se le critica que no conoce muy
bien las dinámicas de económicas o
sociales y si le ha criticado algunos
votos en el congreso de los Estados
Unidos en el senado particularmente en
todo lo que tiene que ver con derechos
sexuales y reproductivos sus posiciones
han sido bastante criticadas al interior
del Estado No necesariamente se aleja
del ala mayoritaria del partido
demócrata y por lo tanto se considera un
senador firme con las disposiciones del
partido entonces ahí Creo que está su
venta Qué puede pasar hoy
ha votado aproximadamente 1,8 millones
de personas de manera anticipada menos
de lo que votaron en el 2022 que era
menos de lo que votaron en 2020 que era
aproximadamente 2,5 millones eso puede
tener un lastre para los demócratas pero
se espera que hoy masivamente salga la
gente a votar eso sería positivo para
los demócratas y no sé si sea tan
positivo para los republicanos será una
elección bastante competitiva que
difícilmente conoceremos los resultados
hoy en la noche sino que tal vez una
semana se demoren en salir
definitivamente recordando que el pasado
8 de noviembre la diferencia entre uno y
otro fue de 0,9%. Entonces será una
elección bastante competitiva en la cual
se finalizará un proceso que inició el
pasado 8 de noviembre Rafael también
hablemos de la participación de los
jóvenes hablando de las elecciones de
mitad de mandato de este de mitad de
mandato este 2022 que fue la segunda más
alta en casi tres décadas la importancia
también de joven en las elecciones de
hoy en Georgia sin duda alguna a los
jóvenes tradicionalmente se les critica
de que son vociferantes en términos de
apoyar un candidato pero poco eh
receptivos el Día de las elecciones eso
que demuestra creo que en términos
generales el discurso demócrata
alrededor de La amenaza de las
instituciones de la defensa de la
democracia caló en los jóvenes y sin
duda alguna los sacó a votar pero al
mismo tiempo los jóvenes se inclinan más
por
formas de votación distintas a las
tradicionales que es el Día de votación
y en ese sentido las leyes que han sido
aprobadas en el estado de Georgia en los
últimos dos años Pues limitaron un poco
ese periodo de hecho recuerde que las
votaciones iniciaron una semana atrás
cuando antes iniciaban mucho antes y ese
tipo de elementos digamos que limita un
poco la votación de ese grupo
poblacional que es disperso y que es a
veces difícil de llevar a las urnas en
el día electoral hablamos
de el candidato demócrata Rafael
warnernock Realmente si él ganaría estas
elecciones esta segunda vuelta podría
mejorar la gobernabilidad del presidente
Joe biden o no es tan así no No
necesariamente están influyente pero lo
deja muy bien parado para las elecciones
del 2024 Por qué Porque reflejaría que
en Georgia Hay posibilidades de volver a
ganar recordemos que en las elecciones
del 2020 el presidente Joe biden ganó
por un estrecho margen y eso no se
presentaba desde que Jimmy Carter
georgiano se presentará a la elección
presidencial en los Estados Unidos
entonces Si usted me lo pregunta No
necesariamente mejora la gobernabilidad
en el congreso pero sí deja bien parados
a los demócratas para enfrentar en el
2024 al oponente de quien sea el
representante demócrata no sabemos si
sea el presidente Trump no sabemos si
sea otro que en las primarias pueda
obtener la mayoría de votos necesarios y
ser el contrincante de El representante
demócrata hablas de estas elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 analizando
digamos lo que fueron estas elecciones
de medio término Cómo ve las dos fuerzas
políticas para dirigirse a estas
elecciones los demócratas o los
republicanos quién podría A lo mejor
estar liderando Esta carrera por la Casa
Blanca en dos años cada elección es una
historia distinta hoy a los demócratas
les puede relativamente bien porque
supieron defender posiciones y perdieron
menos de lo que se esperaba pero hace
falta cerrar el capítulo de Georgia que
se cierra el día de hoy y si ganan yo
creo que entran bien posicionados pero
faltan dos años y en estos dos años los
republicanos que controlan la cámara
baja son los que van a determinar que
proyectos de ley se van a discutir
Cuáles son los tiempos que le van a dar
a eso y digamos que pueden generar como
como un rezago en de lo que logre el
congreso que es importante y sigue
siendo determinante si Estados Unidos
sigue su senda de recuperación si se
mantiene baja la inflación creo que
podrían llegar en buena posición para el
2024 hace falta mucha tela por cortar
muchos proyectos por aprobar y sin duda
alguna la inestabilidad internacional
también puede jugar un peso importante
ha disminuido en las últimas encuestas
el apoyo que el estadounidense siente a
la guerra ruso ucraniana Por ejemplo ese
es otro elemento que puede pegar que
puede seguir pegando Cómo se vayan
desarrollando las relaciones frente a la
República popular China y frente a sus
aliados europeos Entonces el escenario
digamos sigue siendo inestable hoy los
los demócratas este año digamos en las
elecciones de armo y no lo hicieron
relativamente bien pero en el 2024
podríamos contar una historia
completamente diferente dependiendo cómo
avance la economía cómo avanza el país y
por supuesto lo que hagan los
republicanos